welcome back to trash Tuesday today in studio as
our current kalila replacement we have someone
very similar I've also Bobby Lee welcome back
Mark Normand good to be back well this is the
first time I'm in the in the studio yes I was in
your weird little therapy in New York I have no I
was like I had so much fun over that one I was
so for the therapist it was I was like what is
going on here we bought this we got close that
was proper bonded yeah and congrats on the new
special I started it last night it's so funny oh
geez thanks and it's called Soup To Nuts you got
it sister and it's all over my Netflix it's crazy
on Netflix it's all over my nose I'm nutting all
over it that'd be a great porn site Netflix not
flicks I gotta get that domain or it's like a game
you guys play when you're teens yeah yeah Bangkok
remember that how does it feel like how does it
feel to have it out it's been out for a couple
weeks now it's bittersweet because uh it's doing
well people seem to like it but then they come
out and see you and I got no new stuff I know so
you're like now I gotta pump that [__] out any
ideas audience right right I've got the paper out
there there it just has swastikas on it but uh
yeah it's just I've got to pump it out because
they're like coming to see you and the agents are
like go make more money yeah like I need a minute
to build material yeah and the Agents won't
let it happen no no they won't all their other
clients are on strike so they're like we need to
do it I loved how in the opening you started with
like having audience like the audience shout
stuff out and you reacting to it because I do
feel like that's become a very big part of stand
up especially like developing new stuff or just
like if I'm trying to get like a crowd work clip
or something right so I was really excited to see
that incorporated in a special but how often are
you not pulling that off like how often are they
throwing something off and you're like good next
yeah a lot of editing in there a lot of guys like
I'm uh Pakistani and you're like good job I love
your people you know I know how to pack a fanny
um foreign [Music]
let therapy be your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help hllp.com
Tuesday head to factormules.com trash50 and
use code trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeals.com trash 50 to get
50 off hello sluggies um what a fun episode
thank you for joining us um I am on the road
on the welcome to anniewood tour you can see
me in San Francisco at Cobbs that was so fun it
sold out last time I can't wait to see you guys
September 15th and 16th I'll be in Austin Texas
in October La Jolla in October at The Comedy
Store I think I'll be filming my special there
so that will be extra special and I'll be in
San Jose and Houston and a lot more dates are
getting added so go to annieleterman.com shows
and you can see me every Thursday on anyone and
uh Annie wood and friends at The Comedy Store
the date will be posted so check my Instagram
um I don't know the exact date yet but
you will see it September something
hi you guys I am so psyched that for the first
time ever I'm coming to Madison Wisconsin in
two weeks September 14th through 16th I'm
really looking forward to this I'm definitely
a cheese Midwest girl and then I'll be in DC
Boston um San Diego Detroit Chicago San Jose
and more you can get tickets at Esther
onice.com I can't wait to see you guys
[Music]
now I'm gonna shoot a special suit and I was
thinking I like pace so much that I'm the
editing is going to be hard like all of a sudden
I'm going to be like over in one corner that'll be
fine I mean Chris Rock is like a [__] yeah but
didn't he do his live where you watch the whole
thing well his old ones are paced yeah you'll
be fine but then he goes to like Africa in one
remember he like oh yeah he like all of a sudden
isn't like another yeah in another outfit there's
black people and then there's Africans but yeah he
pays you'll be fine pacing is good it keeps people
interested do you do that at all your live shows
where you take like the audience stuff is that
why you Incorporated it in the special no because
uh hey I hadn't seen anyone do it and everybody's
like you gotta get them up top they click out
after like two seconds if they're bored so I
was like put that in the front so it's it's kind
of action-packed a little yeah I love the opening
like because I'm from Chicago oh it's so cool to
see the L represented in TV yeah I'm so excited
um what made you decide to in Chicago well I
kind of blew my load in all these cities you
know we're going to shoot at this date and I'm
like well I've just been here I've just been
here I can't sell another ticket in Chicago we
hadn't been to in a minute so we did it there
and it's a great comedy town as you know yeah I
was so I was also extra excited because the Vic
where you shot it is there was once a Dropkick
Murphy's concert there that I didn't even know
what they were about these cool kids invited
me and my parents wouldn't let me go so like
the Vic had like a very childhood like a headphone
yeah yeah wow you were a drop kick gal no I I not
at all oh I just wanted to see who friends were
going the cool people got it and my parents were
like this is not happening well that was a good
protection though yeah easily drop kicked no I
fully would have died yeah you would have
gotten killed but I'm the only idiot that
booked the theater I was like the theaters open
book it and it was Saint Patty's Day oh that is
the worst hammered one guy like hit his girlfriend
stopped the show it was wild to jerk off yeah yeah
wait because you know in Chicago St Patrick's Day
is insane oh yeah and at my college which is the
University of Illinois Champaign Urbana they
have something called unofficial St Patrick's
Day where like all the kids start drinking the
Friday before St Patrick's Day at like 8 A.M all
day so maybe it's because the school is called
champagne that could be why is it the longest
name of a school what is it called University
of Illinois in Champaign okay there's two cities
which I don't fully understand either but were
people like so reckless hammered yelling out
stuff a lot of that front part of the special
with the crowd work was them being shit-faced
they started the crowd work sometimes it happens
like I guess we're going here you gotta go there
and it's a Netflix statement so you're like I want
it to be perfect yeah and then you see some guy
like blow me he's like oh [__] but uh we we
pulled it together and we we got something out
of it were you nervous terrified I was like this
is my shot wait did you do one show we did four
just for that reason in how many nights one two
nights two so funny to pack in four on St Patty's
Day like let's see how many [__] up people
we can get in here a lot of editing I'm always
performing on the worst every I've never taken
like the right weekend off ever I'm always like
oh sure this weekend's open I'll do it and it's
always it's always a drinking thing yeah you're
in Winnipeg and like February oh yeah no wonder
no one would take this I'll be like I always go to
like Tampa during their like pirate festival I'm
like [__] everyone's always coming with like peg
legs one time I had a guy who literally come in
with an eye patch wow but it wasn't it was Tampa
but it wasn't until I was like oh are you doing
like the thing but are you trying to pretend that
you didn't love that I was very excited about it
I asked if I could sign under the eye but did you
do any hard hours but yeah there's always some hey
the uh Strawberry Fest is in town or whatever and
you're like God and then it is like their main
thing yeah for [__] sake we're gonna go pick
strawberries and then it's like why can't you pick
strawberries and then come to the show I know or
like I went to St Louis or somewhere I went uh and
they were having like an old-fashioned car thing
I'm like you can't look at cars and then come to a
show right right yeah and they always they always
say it to help you when you don't sell tickets
they're like well it's not it's not you it's you
know Comic-Con is here or the the kids what do
you call those uh where they beauty pageant with
the little kid those are hot you're like yeah that
doesn't can conflict yeah no no counter uh cross
culture here no I wish my agents would do that
that would be awesome to give me like I just go
there and then the owner will tell me and I'm like
okay at least you're not mad at me right right
they're always nice well it's July everybody's
out of the boat you know there's always some
excuse they're mad I feel like they're mad they're
like so pissed at me they'll be like well I'm like
[__] you where's your marketing exactly when
I started comedy you would go to a club it'd be
full and then you'd leave they didn't know who you
were and it was fun and then they take out of here
if you look at the breakdown they take out of your
expenses like 600 for like promotions yeah where I
know and then what if you're a sellout like what
if you're a draw yeah give me that I know well
here we are guys if you want to know the insides
of yeah sorry what our contracts are wait so Mark
are you actually like literally on tour right
now as the special just came out yeah I don't
know what that means when people say are you on
yeah exactly but because that seems so like you
said so difficult you just burned like your hour
oh yeah what are you doing up there it's about 20
minutes of stuff I got some stuff that I kind
of had on the back burner and then 30 of like
so black people are late you know just like trying
to uh and Filipino as a parent I feel like we
should call crowd work uh back burner back Hannah
burner oh she's taking it over I like it I like
it but I will say um that is a fear of mine too
because I've like the idea of having to go with
all new stuff but do you like announce this is new
I feel like Taylor Thomason does that she's like
come see me work stuff out that's like I'm gonna
do that every time guys this is my first time
ever doing these jokes I'm so proud of you it's a
killer hour but you're like I'm working it out I'm
just that good yeah so you got to say that up top
and I think some people like it they're like oh
he's got the notes up here or whatever but I think
most people are like you know I paid a little I
have a look at you I have a guy who he comments
on every time I go to Philly he like he's like
she brought notes out it was like 2014. it was
like my first headlining gig I'd ever done yeah
he's like she brings notes out don't go I'm like
come on man what really I'm like come on give me a
break [__] give me a break what's up with these
losers these Reddit queefs well you know when you
like know them they're there so often how do I
recognize you and you're like do you love me or
do you hate me I know why are you still around or
like still like you haven't left me all you do is
criticize me but you know every single thing about
me you know more about me than my father it is
weird but I know them by their name though there's
one guy that like he kept bothering like he would
give two like detailed he would say things like
um he said like I liked Andy so much more when
she lived in her car like she was so much before
she like had a boyfriend I was like you want me
to like be like miserable suffering starving
to death exactly and then I like got mad at
him once and then he was like you shouldn't know
my name I was like Ron he's like how do you know
my name but now he like comes to myself I'm like
runs here Ron's gonna kill you one day no wrong
turns on me again and I'm like now that I [__]
have acknowledge you can't turn on me again yes
he's like the Selena fan club guy you know I mean
Esther don't act like if we don't have some no but
that's so funny that your own fan was like why do
you know my name it was the perfect answer that's
the best comeback ever like I want to say that
to someone one day you shouldn't know me never
been signed too we'll do live shows for Tuesdays
with stories and we're like oh that guy's here
again that we know our whole audience yeah not
good I mean we're glad you come but uh it's a
little embarrassing well though it's how do you
feel about people that come multiple times in the
weekends that is the worst well she's like I want
to do new material I'm like I I have like it's
psychotic but I'm like I want everyone to have
like a completely unique experience of course of
course so it's like when they come you're like
[__] I'm just gonna redo I don't want to put
those things in the same order totally takes the
magic out of it they're like oh I see behind the
curtain now because a joke has to be a surprise
yeah like oh I know where this is going and they
always say no I get it but they're not laughing
yeah I'm like [__] you yeah we need you we're
feeding off you yeah I feel like um I went to she
told me that I can't mention this but I have to
mention it every episode I went to the Nickelback
concert whoa and uh it was Monument so I can't
help it you just saw Taylor Swift and you're
bringing up Nickelback well because Taylor Swift
doesn't have this problem okay so the issue that
Nickelback has is the opposite of us where they
the fans only want the hits they don't want
any new stuff so they have to sneak new stuff
in and everyone's like so bored and sitting
down in their seats looking at their phones
and then with us it's like I mean it would be
heaven to be able to do this it would be Heaven
I don't think you would enjoy it though but you
could pull them out like to be able to pull out
like a bit you know has been killing for 15 years
okay so I have an alternate point of view on this
and I don't know if this is where I stand I just
want to present it but like all right Jonah Hill
with the therapy truck I always have an alternate
point of view I was um I recently did a show in I
think it was Raleigh or Atlanta or one of those
places but like afterwards these girls came up
to me and they were like wait we're so upset you
didn't do the dog fetish bit and it was like what
because I so I started this is exciting I started
posting like some of my material as clips and I
I've been so insecure about it I'm like I can't
do those bits like people have seen it and Dave
keeps telling me like nobody cares do it and then
for that to happen where they're like no we want
to see what you posted that's very exciting
and you're doing God's work that means that
means we're changing the what they want and if
that if that is what they want that I can give
that I can deliver I can deliver already written
jokes that I know work yes it's writing the new
material that's the hard stuff but but um I feel
like it's okay to do that as long as you don't
hesitate beforehand and deliver it weird because
you feel weird about it because I have I had like
my Kanye Yeezy bit that did really well online
and then I feel guilty doing it but sometimes it
just comes up like someone's wearing Yeezys and
I want to go into it and if I if I do it where I
feel weird and like guilty or something it doesn't
do as well totally but if I go like deliver like
they've never heard a noise as well no yeah you
have to sell it like ever like with everything
I mean do you ever do repeats or have people come
up to you and be like why didn't you do this yeah
but I don't trust them because it's always one
guy or two guys they don't speak for the whole
audience so I think if you just play like all new
they're happy yeah but it was at least go watch it
at least encouraging that like for me like I can
I feel like I can post clips of some things and
still do them I agree Clips is one thing a special
I think is different but a clip yeah although like
yeah sometimes like a topic like will come up
that's something I did in my special and I'll
just throw it out yeah if it pops into her head
yeah in the moment or whatever is anybody getting
this I think there's some guy driving a truck
going all right yeah it's always weird how people
get in a relationship and they look shittier I'm
like so now the person you love has to deal with
your disgusting you are yeah well I look at Todd
and I'm like now I never I never care about like
what he eats or anything and now that we're
getting I'm like you are not gonna be like a
bald fat guy there you go good for you I won't
allow it and I just smack the taco out of his
hand and get the [__] out of him yeah you hear
that lizzo that's right lizzo and I make him eat
the banana out of my [__] I like that scenario
to me is like there's no if there's no way it was
bad no there's no way damn come on and also we
got into rock and roll it's fun you know what do
you go be an accountant if you don't want to eat
a banana out of someone's snatch I was talking
to faheem last night at the store and he had a
good point he was like we've all been sitting on
these lizzo fat jokes but we're like I don't want
to be mean but now it's like all right at least
Beast good stuff somebody had a great line they
said uh I'd stand by lizzo but there's no room
I got a tweeter on stage that was it somebody
tweeted it's on stage it's not gonna nah nah
it's a written that's a horrible when you do
okay sorry we're going back into County no it's
I could talk comedy all day it's hard to not talk
comedy what else we're gonna talk about your wife
when did you get married November 11 2022.
uh no it was in New Orleans it was a perfect
night she killed it she planned the whole
thing it was awesome you just had to show up I
just had to show up I did shrooms did you yeah
I was thinking how [__] up I want to be on my
wedding it helps because it's comics and family
it's worlds colliding and it's emotions you know
and I'm not good with that so I took some shrooms
which might have been a mistake because I was at
the altar and she looked like already Lang face
was all warped you were never harder yeah yeah
exactly I'm Marrying the wrong person I do love
Artie Lange Hardy Lang is a king do you have any
sense of what you do want to have for your wedding
I'm really like I just want no pressure and fun
family like whatever is that your drink Rock no
monster monster no I do uh five hour energies
oh wow you're an animal yeah how do you do it
you must be [__] blood yeah all right so I like
to [__] blood it feels good makes me feel alive
there's no blood on my toilet seat what am I
doing you got a bidet of course I did my first
day a week ago and man it is life changing it's
amazing amazing and they make them very affordable
like I'm sorry they really do yeah but you can
do a range of them there's one in here there's
like a nice like Japanese toilet I'll be [__] I
like you can pick what color you want the lights
to be in the water damn yeah my [__] comes out
purple I do it blue so it comes out purple I was
on staying at an Airbnb that had a toilet that
when you walked up to it it would lift the lid
and I was like I don't know how I'm ever gonna
go back to life without this without the toilet
acknowledging your presence yeah and then I
realized my toilet at home the lid is always
lifted like this isn't a service I need so stupid
but like I got used to it it feels good seeing it
go up like this yeah if you ever worry like
the wind will blow and you'll fall into it
I want to remake the um Inner Space with you
what's that remember wouldn't that be good
great idea uh Martin Short uh Quinn Dennis Dennis
Quaid not Randy Randy my favorite Quaid but I have
partied with Dennis Quaid he gets yes and it's
a great story he's a hunk so she he gets shrunk
down and then he gets ingested by Martin Short so
he's like in his body but he's like a tiny wait I
want that there it is you could be either Martin
you could play either character honestly it's
like the Magic School Bus yeah it is remember
that it's a Magic School Bus for adults yeah
fun oh it's like Honey I shrunk my uh oh yeah my
lunch a lot of shrinking in the 80s it was weird
never noticed that before now all shrinks yeah
therapy joke yeah I like it wait so Mark have you
um seen any Taylor Swift concerts lately no
I can't afford it uh I don't I don't care for
the music I'm I'm impressed with her I just it
doesn't connect with me I'm a heterosexual 39
year old I will say two I went to the concert
there were like boyfriends there I did not see
any true straight men like with their Bros going
to the concert which I was surprised I thought she
transcended really I feel like Naper gotzi loves
Taylor Swift yeah so yeah they're out there but
he has a daughter and a wife so it could be the
daughter involved involvement but it I was so
impressed by her I felt like sad I didn't know
more of the lyrics She did 44 songs wow and I
know like two two songs really well that I really
like and I realized I don't even know the lyrics
to that and it was like oh you feel like such a
loser wow everyone knows I know it's it's Bizarro
land but when you're there you're in her world and
it's like you are the loser I mean every single
or she went with Nikki Glaser which I can't even
imagine Nikki knew everything it didn't get like a
sign Nikki was trying to be like the little girl
she like gives the hat too it should have been
um no Nikki just like it was so funny to
watch her just truly know every single word
this show is sponsored by betterhelp sometimes
we're faced with Crossroads in life and we don't
know which path to take that happens to me all the
time I'm always in some what do I do liminal space
look we have annoying friends we have friends we
talk about this on this episode we have people
that that are negative or take a long time on
the phone and therapy has been an indispensable
um part of my life so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a licensed
therapist and switch therapist anytime for
no additional charge and also like better health
has this really cool Journal feature which I love
where I'm able to kind of put down my thoughts
in between my appointments and I can bring them
up with my therapist on our next appointment so
I love that feature also like the best part about
it is that if you don't Vibe with a therapist
which happens a lot by the way and it's no fault
no fault of theirs or yours sometimes sometimes
it's just not a match it's that easy to switch
I know there's so many times I've just gone back
to people because it's like too awkward right but
better help makes it very very easy let therapy
be your map with better help visit betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday
guys we're busy not only are we busy but some of
us can't be trusted to cook for others okay that
is fine factor is America's number one ready
to eat meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door honestly
cooking portioning I don't I can't like I'm a
busy woman I'm on the go and Factor meals are
so delicious and they're healthy and they make
things so easy and you can choose from over 34
weekly flavor pack dietitian approved meals ready
to eat in two minutes and level up with Gourmet
plus options prepared to Perfection by chefs
and ready to eat in record time which is very
important to me treat yourself to upscale meals
with premium ingredients like broccolini leeks
truffle butter and asparagus varicus and also
if you're looking for like a calorie conscious
option ahead of a busy season try delicious
dietitian approved calorie smart meals with
around or less than 550 calories per second I
tried to have the weight the the the scale to
weigh out my food I'm it's just not for me it's
not going to happen so I can't personally count
my own macros that is something I will never
do in this lifetime not it's not worth my time
it's not worth my life and so Factor doing it for
me is what's up head to factormeels.com trash50
and use code trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeels.com trash50 to get 50 off
play your comments I don't know if you've
read yours you should never read them why
it's wild just oh man she looks like a
kid to take that diaper pull to the side
they can't be that overt about it but they
really they do think they've discovered you
like in a daycare center like yeah
come on that is not true this hot
toddler she's definitely doesn't have
pubes you know I got a hymen all kinds
of stuff I'm gonna [__] her in her
baby ass yeah that I regret writing
she's a spinner size they can't help themselves
yes oh my God that's not true you guys [Laughter]
I don't that's the one thing I don't I don't
have the girl little girl thing a lot of guys
love that like young toddler girl oh my God they
do I'm not a lot but oh I do follow Esther I've
never no you finally no you I'm telling you like
in the past two years you now look like you're
in your 20s before it was like I was like they
need to be on a [__] list like it really was
like you looked so young and it was weird but
now I'm like I let them I'm go you can have
at her it's just so weird because people always
trust that you're not doing anything bad always
say this to me and I've literally never been with
anyone who's like let's like play that up like no
one wants really yes yeah oh I assume the whole
thing yeah no your dates were at a playground so
you're having a Capri Sun they Spike her like
little like Juice Box yeah yeah exactly have
some Flintstones like a little juice box a little
juice box the squeezer a little liquid comes out I
identified so I go on a daily to shake their keys
in your face I mean see the sad thing is I would
love that like a date at a playground sounds so
fun no one wants no you do like to be baby that
is funny I know no guys because they look like
pedophiles yeah they they want it because you
look so little like if they were to do that like
Dave would probably carry around in a Baby Bjorn
oh that would be fun I would never do that that's
why you're naked but she's naked yeah and going
out what what do you even mean pacifier the whole
thing cradle stroll you in a stroller would be fun
this is unfair um what is it like trying to change
the subject married to a fellow stand-up comedian
it's good and bad it helps because you can have a
dialogue about it yeah I can feel her jokes it's
a good premise but I kind of am the one with the I
could do them I'm on tour baby let's go yeah it's
good because you can have a dialogue about comedy
like we we all have talked about comedy you can
do that with her so she gets everything it's not
like who what's a Comedy Central presents what's a
tag you know she understands everything but then
it's also like to explain what your credits are
yeah what's a premium blend uh but yeah then but
then it's hard because she's on the road I'm on
the road and uh we're all trying to we're sitting
at dinner like are you gonna use that really yeah
wait that's actually so fun that you're actually
sitting at dinner and like coming up with bits to
the point where you have to like divvy them up
oh yeah no that's so annoying are you kidding
comments it's been the worst or it's like someone
kind of like has the premise and then the other
one does the punch line and then you're like no
no yeah or then when you see your ex and they're
like still doing your punch lines and you're going
and they're getting like the best and you're going
oh I want to tell people that was mine yeah
that's true I want to tell people I did that
or you're having sex and something silly happens
and we're both kind of like that whole queef chunk
like she queef but I thought about
yeah yeah a little baby arm comes out
the old miscarriage that's what I call her uh
for marriage for miscarriage oh that's great yeah
we'll be on the race towards it we have to fight
we have to fight over our premises you guys want
kids is that in the cards it's in the freezer I
got them nice and Frozen up boys or quarter Asian
boys nice oh is he Asian yeah I never thought I'd
see the day yeah can you believe it I'm bringing
Asians back wow well done there Shang Wang is
cute yo funny guy yeah he's a great comic cool
dude he's kind of got a little swag he does his
hers like all along now I saw him in Montreal
and he was doing jokes about like turnips like
smashing doing these jokes about I'm like God
I wish I could do one of those yes I just wish I
could be one of those like green onions and he's
like just destroyed that's leveling the place I'm
like [__] like I like yeah he's great he's got
a bit about salmon it's the only like Salmon's a
color like I have a salmon shirt he's like it's
the only color based on the inside of an animal
and you're like yeah that is scary and it's like I
don't know if he smokes pot or just gives Vibes a
smoking pot like it's like he took like high ideas
and made them right right Classics we just had
Whitney on the podcast and she's pregnant right
now and I feel like that all gave us like a little
bit of baby fever does that does that ever happen
for guys an abortion fever but it's like serotola
mosh Rosebud Whitney a lot of people are getting
Prego it's it's the season it's really uh bringing
like coveralls back too yeah yeah to me that looks
like the worst thing you'd want to wear when you
have to peel uh oh good point like a onesie but I
guess I don't know but you all you got your first
three minutes hey I'm trying to kill it I didn't
want to keep it hey I'm not gonna keep it you
know whatever it is so you got like three minutes
oh I'm crowning let me better yeah yeah exactly
Rosebud we did a fully loaded and she you know
it's 18 000 people and she would just walk out and
be like don't worry I'm not keeping it yeah oh my
God kills she kills the baby right yeah obviously
wait do you feel like you want kids I I want the
25 year old at dinner at Thanksgiving and we
can all get along but I don't want the sleepless
nights the [__] the grades the school projects
the all that [__] the uh period oh isn't that
good that you're the dad yeah I really don't have
to have any of it does not do that that's true I
know I feel like it's interesting that it's good
I feel like Ali Wong does all service by doing
like her pregnancy specials because before that
I just remember thinking like wow having like
a kid as a female comic sucks and having a kid
as a male comic is like like career change all
this material you're now relating to the world and
then I and I always felt like it was like uneven
but now I think it's good point yeah Wong did two
pregnant specials Schumer did one pavitsky did a
pregnant thing what is it sorry a lot of Pollocks
around here I've never known the difference isn't
that funny I know literally I've been calling
you the wrong you didn't even notice what he
said Christina P yeah she does us the service and
Esther does a little Esther for us yeah Whitney's
gonna do one too yeah no it's now it truly is a
trend I kind of love it yeah yeah we need a first
man pregnant special it's coming my fiance doesn't
look like the pregnant man speaking of pregnant
men oh my God Walk of Shame block of Shame whose
Bed were you I'm gonna have to have whose bed
where you live you're dressed like you had to
throw on your merch shirt to get here it's calm
it looks like the Playboy Bunny sticker
that I want for my no I honestly thought
we were starting at one time I should send an
extra reminder I almost did no it was my fault
it's my fault my fault it's all my fault I'm
so happy you got here before one you're good
you're early I love when other people are late
it's like my favorite thing in the world this
is one and not an intentional late though this
is like I really thoughts aren't intentional
um what's what's up guys what are we what are
we talking about preggo comedians I don't I
didn't get any baby fever from from it was like
baby fever from Whitney but it was like if this
person is having a baby because she seemed last
time I talked to her she was like it would be
archaic for me to have a baby right so I was like
okay we're not having kids and then she's like
praying I'm like [__] are we having kids right
God damn it Whitney what the hell and that's gonna
be the strongest baby ever because the Percocets
and the purple ball that that baby's fighting off
in the womb dodging like the Matrix no that's a
silver baby that's a summer baby no you're right
I I think I'm gonna well I told the girls that I
was probably just gonna settle for like a truck
a guy at a truck stop and just whatever knock
it out yeah whoever will travel whoever [__]
me effectively first is the baby now I okay so
wait I like that term effective cream pie yeah
effective because all cream pies are effective
there's slow motility some of the sperms are
broken up like you want it you want it with
pulp not without with pulp oh my God you're
right have you ever checked your sperm no but I've
gotten two girls pregnant in my day [__] yeah
I think I'm okay you're good yeah that's right we
talked about this you paid for three or two three
in my day and you only and you're the father of
only two yeah one was like a wayward sister right
right there's just some black guy outside I was
like I got it and do you offer immediately are you
like hey I got this or is it you offer because
you want to be a gentleman but you're secretly
like I need this to happen right so I'll pay for
it I'll make sure that money's not like an issue
and do you go with them and you give them like
porridge after like to you know porridge well
that I have my sister makes the best abortion
porridge abortion porch sounds like like the
meat that comes out it does you add it on top
no but I I she does she makes this like really
it's kind of like roscaldo but it's really good
I know you were kidding but you know how people
eat like the placenta yeah does anyone eat their
fetus is that what they mean Annie and I want you
guys to go on Reddit Sam tripley's read it and
figure that out wait a second but do you are
you there throughout the whole process are you
like following up I'm following up make sure
yeah but uh two were in New York so you know
it's a walking City so wait what is the pill
the pill just is supposed to go in and just kill
it uh yeah but you have oh it it was excruciating
for me the worst things about the abortion pill
it really caused it forces contractions so it's
a really oh you have to deliver the baby that's
so sad basically yeah it basically feels at least
for me I don't know I think some girls it works
you know I don't usually get period cramps so
the feeling of cramps is not um it feels like
period cramps times ten yeah and you're just
sitting there waiting for it to pass and you look
down you're like I think that's it but it I wonder
if getting kicked on the balls and period cramps
feel the same yeah I wish I could just have balls
one second to do what it feels like worst feeling
I got hit in the balls uh I posted on my Instagram
and it was a football right to the balls I was
out for a half hour really yeah you feel in your
stomach it's it's really you've got like nauseous
kind of get nauseous you get like waves of pain
it's brutal I felt like a lady I had a heating
pack on me nice Scream Wait where is the train
where does the pain travel to like in your abdomen
yeah it goes up it like hits the intestines I
don't know because it's all connected like you
have to shut no not really but it won't go away
it lingers at pain I feel so bad I was such a
ball puncher in Middle School oh my brothers
my brother in the ball's so bad do you think if
you have balls you'd be safe you punched men in
the balls that was not men yeah just not men yeah
we're flirting balls are you serious guys flick
each other in the balls balls are always getting
it's so sensitive it's a perfect Target also yeah
it's a [__] it looks exactly like the speed bag
but wouldn't you be kind of afraid that there's
like something sexual about that well there were
all guys that had crushes on oh really yeah some
dick in there I didn't know what's in front of
the ball it was my first hand job technically
my first true hand job was much more brutal than
that oh those are the worst they probably would
have been like the teenage just like but if you're
happy someone's touching your people that's true
my handjobs are still brutal I'm terrible at
hand jobs it's just getting going forward okay
just go to the mouth we're at that age we're
still doing dance clubs what are we doing here
yeah because I have TMJ and I have nasal valve
collapse I could die giving a [__] so I have
to what a way to go we use the hands
and then she'd be all rigor mortis like
did you see Beau is afraid when um I haven't seen
the air uh yeah there's like a scene where someone
gets like they die like [__] and they're in
rigor mortis in like a banging position and
it's someone that's you've always wanted to see
topless oh no it's a female you've always wanted
to see topless I'm not going to give it away but
um so what do you get to breathe right that might
that's why I use those but then I had to stop
using them because they bruised my nose so I
have this like is there a nasal CPAP you could
do no I'm supposed to get it fixed apparently
it's like the hottest [__] ever there's a nurse
ready to just give you like press compressions if
you die you get a piece of my ear and they use it
to like open up my valves they have done that no
they haven't done it yet I keep waiting because I
don't want to be out for six weeks you'd look cute
though with like a little bruised up nose yeah but
then it's just gonna look like I got a nose job
but if you but you would if you were doing that
you wouldn't just trim it up a little too no they
don't do that I would if something is perfect my
insurance you wouldn't notice okay good nose jobs
you don't notice she does not need a nose job
that would be a nightmare she's a perfect nose
that's a shame because you got some dsls I mean
those lips are made for something and the teeth
are very like they seem like perfect like lightest
scrape just the lightest yeah like a nibble on the
head but they're nurse shark teeth they have no
um my dentist shaved down my incisors when I was
15 without my permission so I have no shark teeth
they cause no injury to penis so you're built for
Beach thank you but apparently the beach babe
yeah and the TMJ doesn't help so that's where
that really horrible hand and then the only way to
help the TMJ is to get BOTOX and then your muscles
aren't strong enough right yeah I'm a waste I'm a
lost I'm a lost lover yeah I don't know what I'm
doing damn it's like a really hot gay guy like
all these girls like him but he just hates clam
because lesbian lesbians I find this is gonna get
ugly I find lesbian guys aren't really you know
they're short-haired flannel boots you know
and but gay guys or smoke shows they're all
ripped and they're all like short hair boots
yeah so that sucks for the ladies that you're
like these gorgeous men are all well also you're
talking about a type of like you're talking about
like Butch lesbians and then so like the gay
guy you're talking about is like a butcher gay
guy too it's like they're like the equivalent of
that type of lesbian is like a guy in like tights
we can sequent like right right that's what we
wouldn't be like yeah because I I love half gay
boys I love boys that have been with other boys
at some point but I'm not attracted to the super
like quaffed hair oh okay gay man I need him to
be a little bit more disheveled and dirty like
all right you know that type even more I think
they're called otters yes [Music] you know you're
like a little hairy thin not too big like there's
bears and there's otters yeah you're definitely an
otter wait am I an otter circus seal you're
more of like a muskrat like little we could use
do experiments on you you crawl in yeah these
are otters wait Mark have you done that I've
done the two guy girls shut up what college
come on yeah and I've done the two girl guy
those guys have done the two guy girl for sure
that's bro we're friends what yeah side by side
worldwide I remember like I think it's more
of like the Community College hang when it's
like you bang like in the hotel room together
yeah they're not like you're just banging next
year you don't really have a choice because
your friends are there you don't have money
for another room and then you're like all right
one person starts buying like what are we gonna
just sit here yeah then she starts blowing the
other guy and now it's on I don't understand
like where was I during the where were you
you were outside the Dropkick Murphy concert
Ryan you're on the phone with your
parents why you're not in the threesome
you made the threesome oh my God that's
crazy like and is that like a fun memory
it probably get threesome because every guy's like
so much bigger than you Annie two people against
one do you feel like you can't believe you did
that like was it do you want to do it again no I
got it out of the system but you know it's College
everybody was wild if your wife was like it's our
10th anniversary it's time no I wouldn't want to
do another guy with the wife oh another girl no
another guy would be like crazy that'd be weird I
mean item 22 is is eating his words oh he's so sad
now he's so salty about it I don't blame him hey
what's going on with that he had like a black guy
for his wife's birthday or for their anniversary
he had a black guy is there no jumper thing yeah
and now he's like he's pissed about because the
guy like wasn't respectful it's like they were
disrespectful in what way though was he just like
I think he just banged her out too hard and then
he was maybe talking [__] a little bit he's a
huge guy yeah he's huge big giant boy I thought
with gold chain imagine she brought just like an
emo like a black guy that would be great regular
penis wait did she choose the guy or did he choose
him for her hold on I thought this story was that
the this couple does porn together and then
they decided that she was gonna do a porn with
a different man and the husband was like thought
it was great and cool it was his present to her
okay and then all of his friends and all these
people on podcasts are like why did you do that
and he he like kind of got embarrassed that he let
that happen well he the guy wasn't like nice and
respectful about it is that true I mean I guess
I'm respectful to her not to know about him no
no no he was like talking [__] about the husband
yeah I didn't know that which is hilarious that's
how you want it to end do you want the guy you let
me [__] your wife [__] haha right what am I
gonna be nice yeah I'm gonna be like oh thank you
sorry [__] everyone I would hire Brad Williams
that's my go-to see we recently got um a question
from a fan or someone was approached by a couple
they approached a man asking if he would [__]
the wife and let the husband watch okay and he was
like he didn't want to do it if you were single
would you do that be unicorned into a relationship
would you [__] someone's wife while they watch
I think so yeah really yeah I think so like in
Florida on a gig I would do that but then it's
like yeah as long as I don't have to touch the
guy I had a I used to always get on the road when
I was single I would get so many um random couples
like regular looking couples that would send me
like they'd hit you up through Facebook not hot
like once you see them in the pictures they send
you oh that person's hot I didn't realize they
were hot right but like teachers and [__] like
just regular jobs I think so many people in the
middle States when we travel like they get married
so young that they become freaks yes exactly and
um it was always just so crazy I never would do
it I feel like some Comics out but I'm just like
it I don't I don't know I don't want them to have
I would want them to sign an NDA or something I
want them to have that story about okay that's
what I wanted to ask you have you ever had a
girl sign an NDA have you ever had anyone sign
an NDA before um doing anything sexual to them
no because I recently drafted an NDA really for
somebody and I was like wait is this a bad move
um only because I I don't know like just I'm a
little bit insecure about like the internet yeah
the internet yeah that's so like celebrity Vibes
of you so congratulations well hang on can I read
my NDA yeah oh my God is this allowed I'm the
happiest I've ever this is the juiciest thing
it was a really quick it's like three sentences
long way they'll have to find it so [Laughter]
uh okay so disappointing now guys that hang out
with you are like wait I don't yeah you don't care
it was kind of half jokey but basically it says
I blank name willfully agree to never speak of
change narrative or mention any relation sexual or
not with kalila I hereby give full confidence to
kalila the retelling of our sexual Rendezvous
for her to share all forms of her creative
storytelling in all its forms here and after are
consensual this is not an NDA this is you getting
like a contract sign so you can use the story
oh really yeah yeah but they can't right that's
pretty good is that I think a guy would be fine
with that he wasn't oh what no what'd my wife say
he wasn't he said I reserve the right to tell my
friends if I'm excited about a girl and he could
tell a friend I can't stand it I had okay so I had
this like hot New Zealand guy in my audience I've
talked about this a little bit he was so hot that
I was like I'm like I've never been like I'm in
a [__] audience member but it was like I mean
he was just so hot that I was like I might have
to so I was kind of like joking flirting with
him from the stage and then afterwards he was
like okay what's up let's go you know and I was
like no I don't know I don't think so because I
just didn't try I don't know I don't want him
like writing about me online being a girl like
well I just don't want him like yeah it's like
and then everyone's coming to the shows like
I travel alone a lot of times it's like I don't
want them thinking they can [__] me or whatever
so then and then I was like yeah I don't know man
I I don't know if I'm I'm down and then I did an
Instagram live and all of these like dudes were on
there like are you gonna bang my friend I was like
buddy then he begged me he was like police and I
was like all right oh you did it yeah oh nice I
love that that's so fun what's a hot guy to you
he was just I mean literally so like ripped tall
dark he was from he was um I can't believe you
said ripped yeah so [__] He's from New Zealand
yeah Maori yeah oh this is so [__] hot it was
like a professional athlete of course Annie you
had to it was I could not I'd resisted for a while
but then it was hot because he was begging me so I
was like oh wait anyone else I'm good no but it's
like but it's so different like guys it's like you
guys are you know when you're single or whatever
you can [__] every girl it's tough because a lot
of female Comics like oh it's so unfair women get
hit on blah blah blah but then when women do get
hit on they're like I don't know this is weird
you guys are creeps and I'm like which one is
it ladies if you want to get hit on do you know
I don't think it's unfair that you that I think
it's just it's not it's not like unfair it's just
like it's weird for me to [__] the audience yeah
we're different and it's totally normal for guys
right it's not like I don't think it's unfair it's
just like different I agree because it's like I
mean imagine like you can go to Annie Letterman
shows and she'll suck your dick like imagine what
my shows become if like Reddit was like right
I banged her I banged her I banged her be insane
yeah agreed you want to like break that seal uh-oh
sell out a world tour oh thank you my jaw would
hurt so bad oh good what's going on here there's a
little pre-pussied one's been in the [__] you
have to pick smells like Esther I know Esther's
[__] baby powder paper ice cream wait you don't
like ripped no me neither no we don't like like
chubby chubby you know I like chubby too but it's
like when you get a guy that's just like smoking
[__] hot okay here's here's the deal if he's if
he's naturally just genetically predisposed no not
someone that just like been pumping up but not
a guy who's just a Gym Bro out no way no I feel
like my middle school like my middle school high
school flame my like on and off again was so like
genetically ripped and hot that it's like I I am
like my mom my mom doesn't really need to work
out and she's just ripped my uncle's in the same
way she's genetically gifted right but if it's a
dude with you know spends eight hours at the gym
really counts as macros I'm out boiled chicken
in a tupperware oh yeah that guy's annoying yeah
yeah what is weird it's like what are you doing
and like are you competing is this your thing well
if you're in competition sure that's one thing but
if you just do this yeah but I'm like not I don't
want to go to like my boyfriend's like muscle
competition he's like at a speedo and [__]
it's like it really is pretty good it's super
gay and there's so much like fake it's like spray
tan like not like getting a spray tan like like
they're rubbing Tanner oh no the Tanners that they
use it's like it's black body yeah they use like
10 times darker than it should be I think like any
like sign that men acknowledge their own looks is
like a weird turn off okay like how like like how
like just like men that like care about what they
look like I don't I do like guys with style though
I do like I used to always date skaters because I
feel like they like just have an automatic style
a lot of them and um but I like this younger
generation like the boys with the nail polish or
stuff I think is actually pretty hot really I do
some necklaces on them but it depends but they
have to have like really good bodies oh wow and
they have to read masculine in other ways got it
there's a guy on The Bachelorette who knits and
it's like I'm like he's got to be doing it for
[__] yeah he's so hot it's like come on will
you look this guy up he's so hot why can't he just
have a hobby because and then things are unfolding
where he's like a cheater it's like yeah you're
a cheater you pull them up he's so loud because
I feel like knitting on a really hot guy is like
a high level on a bachelor there is some type of
manipulation happening there interesting ladies
you're interesting because I know a kid in the
90s who would just carry a camera like on his
neck and girls love the camera and I'm like who
gives it about the camera like what about his
face or his body but like the camera's hot no
you're right I recently went on a date with a guy
throw the camera around his neck and it's up here
it was instantly hotter because of it it's weird
you gotta seem like standing up he's like why are
you guys really a camera makes a guy hotter I
see that's why women are tough because you're
all different you guys out okay Xavier and it's
charity a blanket like the sweetie he is he looks
like nerdy there though no he's not he's this is
the guy he's you have to see he's he's hotter he's
but he sucks dick no he doesn't so he turns
out he's a cheater he's not yes he is okay he's
on The Bachelor he's a bachelorette okay okay
this is a good season this which is hilarious
is this the Black season yeah but there's still a
white there's a white guy at the end okay um and
then the next season is their first golden batch
for that one he's like that's just like finally
hilarious my Pace do they keep the same age female
contestants yeah I know that's so scary no but
the women are only gonna be like 40 or something
they're gonna be like we have value and they're 42
or something I literally want my mom to be on that
show so bad you're dead He's 80. like We it's well
this guy's 70. is he 70 yeah he's got a hearing
aid he has a hearing aid and all the jokes are
he doesn't know what social media is it's so funny
no you know what else I want them to do after this
spin-off is like like kind of like our age because
the bachelor was what like they did 30. yeah they
did um Claire this one chick Claire Crawley oh
that was a disaster but left with a guy yeah
that she was there she's like too old she was just
like let's just leave and then they had to bring
in like another person to finish the season
right bam Check Out Time to Pretend I like
all these guys yeah what about Pacino just had
a kid with a young lady and so did Mick Jagger
it's so weird how old is Pacino gotta be 87. the
kid's gonna be [__] so rich like yeah at least
they'll be provided for him that way kalila
had a really old dad that died when she was a
teenager my dad died when I was a teenager but
he was 80 when he died so he was born in 1924.
wow he had me in his well into his 60s wow but
these guys are older than that and that's why
she can't give good blow jobs it's true her dad
could never get hard well I just recently learned
um from Corinne and Christina that guys can
have you when you're at home jerking yourself
off you don't have to be fully hard to come you
can be yes I don't know about that apparently
some dudes can be like just half chub and still
come eyes like ever just tune into girls pockets
and go like they've got this completely wrong we
don't listen yeah I guess you're right you're not
like I'm gonna go listen right we should because
it's good insights for guys guys are so clueless
on what you ladies are into no we literally have
half male listeners okay there you go they should
listen and we give they learn nothing absolutely
nothing but that was a guy who couldn't get hard
he's like trust me guys can come yeah yeah yeah
it was but no you got to be rock hard to shoot a
load really because I think that their producer
Dan was his name down he was the guy in the room
was like no no you're right like you can get a
half chub and just come that way who's producer
oh really yeah he was he corroborated the story
he was like you're right I can't think of anything
scarier in life than like a soft dick coming
like that is that is so nightmare why do you
get the reward when you haven't even like I hate
everything about it you need to stand up like the
toilet seat right when you walk in it goes up
like a barn with an Amish yeah uh oh soft yeah
soft dick is tough even as a married guy I hide
the soft dick really yeah yes it's a bummer nobody
wants to see that the turtle shell yeah yeah
it's like an acorn and a bush [Laughter] right
full bush baby like that plant over there but
yeah if you don't mind the hairs going up the
shaft I lose I might trim a little because
you know you want all the shaft you can get
why not that's got a hair and a gummy bear in
there who knows it's a mess well bush is so funny
um it's been to the movies yeah it's
running mate is gore that's an old
reference George Bush a good time a good
time for politics a fun time fun time yeah
um you voting for Trump I've never voted actually
uh but I like this uh there's a couple interesting
candidates out there that rfk's ripped yeah
zadie he's a dilf yeah but he's kind of sexy
huh nobody no he's cute he's a Kennedy there he
is so hot is he look at his little brother Bobby
Kennedy really yes no so clueless now Annie
do you think that Bobby was the hottest I do
for sure yes not John no what about JFK Jr he is
really hot smoking oh yeah I like how he yelled
at his girlfriend too I was like ooh they were
fighting I know the drama I love all the funny
I was like oh my God passion but the hottest
kid do you think he was banging her out on the
plane when they Annie it was a small plane no he
was flying it no dick looked huge on the plane
yeah that guy's driving he okay he is probably
the hottest Kennedy but personality wise I'm
gonna just predict the I love a typing cover of
murder like I don't understand he like didn't
really accomplish anything in his life and that's
just like oh JFK Jr but he he lost did you do you
know this like George magazine he launched this
like political sexy magazine and it kind of is
embarrassing to me that he did that oh well
because he never got to come to full fruition
let's just say he came with a softie with a semi
what are you his life was like a child that nutted
I um he had the hair swooped that was like he
would have just the celebrity relationships he
would have been in because he had dated like just
Sarah Jessica Parker and stuff like he would have
gone yeah he would have gone so much hotter and
his last wife was really pretty she looked like
Uma Thurman yeah yeah I feel like they were gonna
stay together and yeah are you an Uma Thurman yeah
I like a little bit of Uh something's a little
bit something wonky you know a big dick I mean
I like a face it's not like Heidi Klum doesn't
really she's obviously hot but she's a little
wonky I like a stare at Jessica Parker I
like that big old Jazz I love a big nose
oh especially a big nose on a woman is so sexy
to me Jennifer Gray she got a nose job it was
so weird weird that was her whole thing I agree
with you I think um perfect symmetry is boring
agreed like Chris Hemsworth great but also I
feel like just like boring to look at over time
for me like I find like just the same thing where
something's got to be off a weird mole somewhere
it's like Adrian Brody like that oh my God the
big nose or Ryan Gosling hot take the face is
crazy looking yeah I think you're right I'm sure
in person he's like stunning his face is very he's
not yeah he's various he's like a hot slot the
same really hey you good oh yeah I don't know
if the eyes are closed yeah the ones like winky
kind of lazy yeah and there's been work done to
make it more because it's been crazier in the past
that's probably why he's cool the hair is off yeah
but it is and the nose is a little yeah
interesting it's just blonde men I'm sure
I'd be fully like like slipping
on my own pea juice if I saw him
for you I want you to get
scared so who's your number one
every gal's got a number one I used to say uh
leave Schreiber but what Ben Whitney told me I
just Ray Donovan like I just wanted to just [__]
him through the screen I had no idea and then
um like the Jews I do I know I really haven't
dated you seriously but I do yeah I like him too
my the ladies mine is recently but who's yours
uh Google Al-Qaeda ah what a funny sentence
it should already be on a tab Bin Laden is not
bad looking by the way Bin Laden but Bin Laden
is yeah he likes Filipinos I'm in wait Kyla what
about you I feel like at one point yours was like
a sumo wrestler yeah is that still what do you
really think he's hot he's got a decent face no
Bin Laden is hot no it's more like I don't know
I need to see under the beard I can't decide if
someone's hot unless I've seen no more like I'm
not getting tricked like that more the young guys
like the Isis guys really I agree with you Esther
I can't believe I actually agree with you on this
but I think you're right the dark features
the hairy the big beard is very attractive
for sure but what is yours um recently I've had
had I've gone from any Edgar Ramirez I don't know
who that is is that my Gardener who's that he's a
Venezuelan actor oh yeah he's like um but recent
but my whole life it's been you guys know this
is Bill Murray what yeah a hero you could get him
Bill Murray or Idris Alba either is fine wait okay
but did you watch hijack I haven't on Apple it's
starring Idris Elba you guys it's the best it's
so good and he's amazing in it that guy what about
um that looks like what I'm gonna look like when
I'm older I think I look more like him honestly
um what about did you guys see this I just watched
the show last night it was getting me so girl
boned up but um what was the uh normal people it's
like oh my I was losing Todd's like this guy's
ugly like Todd you do not know what I'm following
every guy thinks is ugly on I'm like I'm already
following him on Instagram have you so I read
this I have like books I should have read the
book I am losing my mind over the show Todd made
me turn it off to watch Big Brother I'm like I am
so horny like why are you doing this to me blue
balled me this show over the pandemic I am like
me and such I love spell I can't because I read
the books I love Sally Rooney but but this guy
like I can understand thinking is that I want to
[__] destroy them I want to circumcise his penis
with my own my own Annie cigars I want to [__]
because I want to just make it happen yeah Paul
I want to [__] that foreskin off him what is it
about him it must be his character it's like he's
rude he's rude he's brooding he's a [__] [__]
but he's kind of sweet that's just good but they
go in on that show they go full Bush they show
everything yeah and Todd's like Todd's like why
would you have a full Bush on him because it's
Grote like you can't show like a shaved beave
on TV but you can show a bush like and that might
even be a merkin right they have to do that do you
know that one of the reasons why people think that
normal vaginas are like the really closed ones
that those are the more common ones are because
and porno mags they used to say you had they had a
Photoshop out any like actual lip showing because
it was too it was like a great pornographic wait
do you have like a TV character movie character or
like a celebrity that's your like number one I'm
all over the road I do like uh SJP uh Salma Hayek
I know is a little hacky but she's a sexy lady
um come on look at that I like you're still
age-appropriate it's good I like older I mean
she's got to grow with them too yeah unbelievable
she's got to be 50. what about Sofia Vergara yeah
too cartoony yeah she's like a you know
[Laughter] also she's got she feels like
she smells like a tortilla you know like she
seems like a real Mexican but she's obviously
hot but yeah but it's not you're like yeah
it's like hanging out with her would be like
all right can you tone it down with the uh
that's one that's one of mine actually oh
I get that that's not a bad choice Pete oh Amanda
Pete very pretty oh yeah I like a big mouth now
have you seen she's gone private government no
pull it up oh no no I'm thinking of someone else
I'm thinking of someone else so you're into your
mouth I like about like big wacky features yeah
huh look at that that's a [__] ear to hear
now when you're at dinner with your parents
or you're like hey past the like is that how you
talk to them I don't speak scared of them still
scared him he's like what do you do for a living
comedy that's what could traumatize you into it
yeah do you try to be funny around them no no
no well they're not big laughers so oh my God
it was brutal and I have friends come over and
they're like man your parents see it's tough to
get a reaction I'm like yes welcome to my world
my parents are the opposite well my mom will give
me just deadpan she'll be like she thinks my mom
like her favorite things like jackass really she
loves like Eric Andre's movie she was like crap
when he got pulled naked yeah she was howling
that's a cool mom howling but if if I'm doing my
dad thinks everything I say is funny and my dad
and I will have like we'll just we'll have these
like moments that are like we're crying we're
laughing so hard and we'll come home and tell my
mom to try to include her yeah and she she'll go
I don't get it and we're like you [__] [__]
[__] live [__] like open up like what are you
she's adopted I'm like We're Not Gonna Leave You
so keep this attitude up I couldn't get my mama
to watch Jackass if I had a gun to her head really
well it's too low brow she's very cultured and she
reads and drinks a glass of wine and listens to
classical but that's kind you went to film school
right yeah I did but I still like jackass I like
[__] up [__] I like farts yeah you know and
it farts her forever I I listen I follow this guy
on Instagram he doesn't have a big following but
it's just farts I think that's his Instagram
handle just farts just farts and it's in the
dark all it's just a video in the dark there's no
asses or anything it's just sounds and he's like
Anonymous I don't like that show your face if
you're gonna be fart guy I want it to ruin your
career right I want you to have to be fart guy I
don't have other options right I definitely don't
agree with you guys on the fart stuff being cute
or fun I don't think it I don't I don't think it
is I would blast you out about if I was your
man yeah part you out of this world [Laughter]
fall right and you don't want that toilet seat
down I would pulling you into the toilet but I
agree with you um in the 10 years I was with
Bobby I never farted in front of him oh my
god well I didn't say that so you do fart in
front of Dave I'm not saying that either but
I just don't think fart humor is like like if
someone walked in the room and was like let one
out and thought it was funny it'd be like pull
my finger is like hacky it's not sure yeah but
like and I there's some people but the I've had
the luck of my last few boyfriends Todd included
they've accidentally left shits in the toilet like
kind of early on so I'm like but I'm like thank
God because it's like all right you broke the seal
right oh no you didn't flush it you didn't hold
the thing down that was their worst mistake I like
rigged the toilet what are some early mistakes a
girl can make that's a good question I think uh
flipping out like having a meltdown too early is
a huge turn off because you're like all right I
gotta get out of this it's gonna be my life yeah
yeah just over small things yeah what if it's
warranted that's fine that's because Warren's
fine but just like snapping like I'm just having a
bad day that whole thing you're like all right I'm
out this gal's uh ticking Time Bomb that's a tough
one um gross stuff doesn't bother me like you know
if a girl has like toilet paper on her shoe or has
like a little you know weird panty thing you know
it's a weird thing in there you know our snail
Trail yeah that's fine because that's natural
it's more like crying over nothing you know like
she had a bad day at work and she's like I just
said no one respects me and you're like ah this
is brutal poor self-regulation yeah yeah so that
that's a tough one so I would say go fart diarrhea
it up on the walls but uh the the freaking out or
snapping snapping on a friend stuff like that
that's tough you know you're right that's the
first thing I look for when I'm dating a guy
is whether or not they could potentially have
a temper or snap potential yeah because that's
really scary to me I hate it my dad was that way
and it [__] me up saying my mom was super Snappy
and so I would it's like I I had a very eggshell
type of childhood so when I look at a dude I'm
like okay like I like to see him under a certain
amount of stress to see how he copes yeah you
should make little obstacle courses or like
you as well there's cheese and Esther not even in
like a gamey kind of way but I will kind of create
obstacles where I'm like okay if I don't respond
to him in a certain whatever you know like let's
say I'm having a busy day I want to know how he
responds to that sure because if it's in any type
of way like even weird and if we're still in the
first three months like that's a red flag for me
I just always need because I my 80d is so crazy so
it's like I just think I was like patient so I can
always tell when we're ordering food like if I'm
taking too long like because I had a boyfriend who
would like yell at me if I was taking too long and
that's like I I can't have someone like touching
me or whatever it's like yeah I'm like busy I got
things going on up here right but so I can always
kind of like tell in those situations it's like
a patience is like what I need yeah because it's
like I'm it's for me to retrain my ADD would
be like almost impossible oh yeah it's too far
gone I've never I've like never observed a red
flag I feel like I could just date anyone I'm
so pathetic we also think that we've also seen
the wrong store and go wow anyone complaining
is tough too like a guy or girl like if I had a
guy friend who was like I'm just tired I'm cold
I like somebody who can rally you know after like
half like she got out of her car today she was
like and I was like what's right I thought it
was like obviously like something had happened
in her life she wants it's just so hard I'm like
oh my God this door is like right there you can
make it I don't notice weather that's what's so
funny like you're so temperature I can't believe
you don't notice I can't go unless something
insane is going on it's like freezing yeah
it's so hot like I go to the car I come back and
we're gonna try to be like are we like what what
should I wear a jacket or I'm like I have no
[__] clue wow sometimes like complaining is
not even complaining it's sort of like a bid for
connection it's just it's like when you tell me
like I'm cold and it's I'm like let me get you a
blanket it's I always see it as like I don't think
she's really that cold she just wants to be babied
or wants to be mothered in this well you know that
in her now so yeah you know how to yeah I feel
like though I've had it with my with with my
friends like if you when you first become friends
it's like you Bond on like hating the same people
yeah you know how the friendship's gonna end right
they're gonna start hating you or talking [__]
on you or whatever or if like you like I have
friends where it's like we've I've complained
to them about things so much that like when they
call I know it's going to be complaining and I
have to be like yes hey let's not do complain
today let's not do that and it's it's almost
impossible because I've trained them to do that
right like if I'm annoyed with something they're
doing I did I established that yeah it's good you
can realize it yeah but I'm trying it's like it's
hard and then you want to be rude to people
because you want them to have their feelings
but it's like yeah God damn I'm like they're
I'm like 10 affirmations in you know I'm like
I'll just be able to deal with it
my friend that's like come on look at the
positive when they're like right I'm just
like you got to call someone else it can't be
me today I can't do it yeah I agreed good one
yeah that's high pressure I I have friends
who will not take any less than an hour of
your time like so if they call I have to know if
I pick up this phone call committing to an hour
because they just are kind of long-winded
a little bit a lot to ask yeah so most of
the time I'll be like hey I'll I'll call you this
weekend when I have time actual time for you yeah
I know and I'm so worried about bothering
people that I I could never do that somebody
I would want to call somebody for an hour yeah
that's Insanity well you're so busy liking every
single person's things they post you're so
good at that well I just feel bad like oh
they're gonna be sad this is the first time I've
ever find in my text I forgive you but oh and I
understand but this is the first time ever since
I've known you I'll respond after this just okay
keep the yeah and rolling so you're so good
you wish everyone their happy birthday yeah
it's so sweet really I don't want to leave
it sweet or psychotic I don't know a little
of both but it's every it's like it's wild
Norman's in there always since the beginning
since I met you that's so like polite and but
like that's what I got it my inner child needs
that kind of consistency is what my inner child
craves someone who you know is not gonna miss
you've like called me like hours I've been sorry
I was skiing like you're good oh yeah yeah you're
fearful I think fearful I don't leave anyone
to hang because I know the pain of being left
hanging so I love living here buddy you grew up
in like a sort of egg Shelley oh yeah big eggshell
well speaking of eggshells this egg has hatched
this has been a great thank you so much on the
special tonight on Netflix it's so funny and like
just great and original and weird definitely watch
it Tuesdays with stories are we drunk is that what
it is we might be drunk outside are you garbage
okay you might be drunk everywhere um you know
you love them check out definitely just check out
a special and thank you Mark we hope to see you
again soon thank you this was Illuminating and a
great time and I'm still bummed about the no BJ
comedy hi guys thank you thank you that was fun
thank you
[Music]